macif règne est en train de s'exprimer
après avoir échangé avec son homologue
russe on va l'écouter tout de suite qui
a réussi à organiser cette réunion ça
n'a pas été chose facile
mais il y est parvenu il a réussi à
faciliter ses contacts ce premier
contact entre les ministres des affaires
étrangères russe et ukrainien depuis le
début de l'agression russe contre
l'ukraine
cette réunion
cette conversation
a été à la fois facile et difficile
facile parce que le ministre lavrov
a tenu son discours habituel sur le cren
difficile
parce que
j'ai fait de mon mieux at least pour au
moins
trouver une solution diplomatique
à la tragédie humanitaire qui se déroule
sur le champ de bataille et dans les
villes assiégées
la situation la plus catastrophique se
trouve aujourd'hui la ville de marioupol
qui borde la mer d'azov
la ville est bombardé il a des
bombardements aériens elle est la cible
de tirs d'artillerie je suis venu ici
avec un but humanitaire
et à l'issue de cette réunion une
décision visant à organiser un couloir
humanitaire
pour quitter mario paul hévin mariupol
de quitter marioupol pour les civils est
ce qu'ils veulent fuir
cette zone
cette zone 2 et par les combats et la
peur est un couloir humanitaire
il vous pouvoir
apporter de l'aide humanitaire à
l'intérieur de la ruche malheureusement
le ministre lavrov
mythe n'a pas été en mesure de prendre
des engagements en ce sens
mais il
correspondre avec les autorités
concernées sur cette question ce risque
nous avons également
évoqué la question d'un cessez le feu de
24 heures pour résoudre les questions
humanitaires les plus pressantes
oui les 90 nous n'avons pas enregistré
d'avancées s'il sur ce point il semble
qu'il se la décision revienne à d'autres
acteurs en russie
sommes convenus de poursuivre nos
efforts
[Musique]
pour
résoudre les questions humanitaires sur
le terrain
je suis prêt à se rencontrer à nouveau
sous ce format si bien sûr il ya des
perspectives de discussions
significatives et si la volonté trouver
des solutions je pense que quand deux
mines et ses affaires étrangères se
rencontrent par définition ils ont un
mandat pour négocier des questions
relatives à la paix à la sécurité a le
mandat qui leur a été confiée par leurs
dirigeants par leurs parlements
et je suis prêt à poursuivre ses efforts
afin de mettre un terme à la guerre en
ukraine
de mettre un terme aux souffrances des
civils ukrainienne
[Musique]
et pour libérer nos territoires
les forces d'occupation russes
je vais maintenant m'exprimer en
ukrainien
bonjour
nous nous sommes entretenus presque une
heure et demie avec le ministre des
affaires étrangères russe lavrov en
présence du mot
des affaires étrangères turc a mais vu
le chevauche aux clauses
ministre des affaires étrangères russe a
démontré son professionnalisme pour
pouvoir approcher les deux parties
non je avons
discuté des des objectifs le premier
objectif est d'assurer un couloir
humanitaire au tour de mario paul la
ville de mario poule et thor une ville
en difficulté
deuxièmement
nous avons
décidé d'eux d'instaurer un cessez le
feu de 24 heures pour pouvoir résoudre
des affaires concernant la première
question
j'espère sincèrement que le ministre
lavrov en
communiquera en russie avec tous les
décideurs concernés pour pouvoir mettre
en place le couloir humanitaire
opérationnel j'espère que la fédération
de russie
prendra en considération
les aspects humanitaires
prendra également en considération
toutes les souffrances humanitaires
y compris les souffrances des femmes des
civils des enfants et des bébés pour lui
qui souffre sous les frappes et 2 par
conséquent ils pourront mettre en place
et assurer le couloir humanitaire
deux maris ou paul et entre soul et
motown
non nous ne pouvons pas arrêter la
guerre
si le pays agresseur
n'a pas la volonté de le faire
aujourd'hui